for years y'all talking about this man
had changed the world in four years four
years seriously come on now serious hey
what's up i'm paul dietrich of raisin TV
we're here the day before the Democratic
National Convention kicks off for 2012
we're here at Carolina fest we're
talking to delegates we're talking to
voters we're talking to people and
supporters of Barack Obama we're asking
them whether Barack Obama can still be
considered a liberal he did run in 2008
on on ending the war and it still hasn't
happened yet but he has a point what
about Guantanamo Guantanamo still open
Granna he has not delivered on every
promise he's escalated the drug war he's
rated a lot of marijuana dispensaries
across the u.s. the important thing is I
agree with him more than I disagree with
them whereas with Mitt Romney I really
disagree with most of his current
stances that came here because the
parents came here and they for a long
time Obama was deporting them and and I
think he should be supporting supporting
them not supporting you had a lot of
things about when he hasn't done okay
let's talk about what he done you know
I'm so sick of hearing people talk about
what Obama hasn't done it for years for
years y'all talking about this man who
changed the world in four years four
years seriously come on now series
running in 2008 saying it would close
Gitmo and he would stop deporting
illegal immigrants he would stop
dispensary raids on marijuana facilities
but he's done all of those things I want
to know if you think that Barack Obama
is still a libera
but I think that rushing into the White
House you have to try to govern from the
middle the majority of what marriages
think in the middle Barack Obama
absolutely in my opinion is trying to
govern from the center where he should
be covering he's not as liberal as some
people would like him to be that's
that's for certain is he as liberal as
you want him to be no no I'm very
liberal I like him don't get me wrong I
really like him I wish he were more
liberal but still he is the best hope
for this country what is keeping
Guantanamo open hindering you know the
economy right now nothing well civil
rights I mean the rights of people I
mean he'll get that and the four more
years don't afford here don't get to it
run we can
President Obama run their Obama